[Music]
welcome back to careful boys where we
are very careful boys
so [ __ ] careful bart has an
announcement
yes
it took us so [ __ ] long how long we
just restocked on our amphibious shorts
for variable games
i love it i finally get some
i'm getting steve some i'm getting
anthony jordy has some he gave me like
every single color they're honestly the
best shorts they're very they're very
comfy it's been stuck at the porch like
we had it already it was stuck at the
porch for like two months old wow
they didn't let you just swim over there
and be like can i open the [ __ ] cage
no
honestly we asked them that was it long
beach yeah because the covet rules like
you can't even go to the container you
can't they have like crazy rules that's
so they finally came in i'm super
excited we have them seven colors black
vapor all of this one's give me blue i
don't even know what color vapor is yeah
it's like a light like cream looking
color dude but the cool thing is about
those shorts i wear i wear it without
underwear and it's so soft and i've been
having a lot of bonus from it a lot it's
just like the
on your dress so you just got pre-cum
all up on the inside yup
and it's it's easy to wash oh could you
help with your itchy [ __ ]
is that no my butthole just itches
oh
you think that shipping [ __ ] is a little
bit of a conspiracy though honestly i
don't know dude we had rick here he was
sitting here he's like i can see all the
containers like out because he lives by
the beach now because like all of our
all of our china production as well like
all stopped like we we've had to
resource all of our stuff for our
clothing line and whatnot so it's kind
of like i was inefficient i watched um
why that [ __ ] went down and it all
started with that ever ever grande all
right
yeah really you know what the what is
that tell them about it tell them
remember during kovid everyone was
making memes about the [ __ ] container
that was stuck at the panama canal yeah
that big-ass container ship right they
backed up [ __ ] so hard
because of that that that whole fiasco
how long did it take him to get that out
of that position like a week or
something weird yeah but it it other now
like ships had to make the decision that
they're like should we go around like
the you know africa or should we like
what should we do
do we wait and then that [ __ ] up a lot
of [ __ ] and then the ports on uh on our
end they were backed up i mean uh they
they didn't have enough staff to unload
oh [ __ ] because the first what
five months or something right
there was no shipments coming in because
everyone's like yeah we don't need to
and then people were doing stay at home
amazon buying or like retailing yeah
that's something that no one could have
predicted that sales like online
homeowners are going to go through the
roof
it's through the roof to the point where
america's never seen any type of
consumerism at this rate
so then
then they started putting in all the
orders right so all of a sudden just a
rush of orders came to the ports
and then they didn't have enough people
to [ __ ] unload them
yeah it got crazy it was so crazy like a
lot of our sweatpants so it was like in
the summer time people were blowing
through sweatpants like crazy because
everyone's chilling at home now yeah so
we were expecting like a low amount of
sales and like our sweats and fleece and
joggers but
all of our sweatpants sold out like in
july and [ __ ] we're like what the hell
is happening like this it was the
craziest like sales patterns we've ever
seen might have just announced that
they're gonna keep the ports 24 7 now
finally
so they're unloading 24 7. oh they
weren't 20 no it was just regular like
like work hours what the [ __ ] i know
they should be right it's an intern it's
a freaking port
and uh maybe it's because i was i
definitely was trying to buy the shorts
at one point these guys yeah i was
trying to buy you so much dude pandemic
and it was like all sold out and stuff
um but i think it was also like right
after you guys got in like i don't know
if it's like a new york fashion article
oh men's health men's health was that
wasn't itself yeah oh yeah yeah sure you
guys were immensely [ __ ]
congratulations
[ __ ] what's your problem yeah man dude
how did you know they were on men's
health it was like [ __ ] what like top
like uh fitness or or at home workout
because that was a huge thing like he
said like during the pandemic there was
like a [ __ ] unprecedented rise in
like at home workout slash uh athleisure
type of like stuff so then they did this
article on like maybe like 10 top
nation [ __ ] like workout shorts or
some [ __ ] and barbara brigade's uh
amphibious stress was on there and
they're with nike and lululemon that's
what i'm saying it was crazy these
shorts are good man
buying those sold out yo that's crazy
you went from [ __ ] printing out
t-shirts from that one
to like now getting your own shorts
right next to nike and [ __ ] we it took
us nine months to develop these bad boys
nine months nine months yeah go to
barbell brigade.com we'll put a link in
the description below but yeah yeah what
why does it usually take that long or is
it because like you have a small
operation these are very unique that's
also really really good fabric yeah like
the actual material so like you probably
had to go through like hella sources
what kind of sheep do you [ __ ] have
to shave to get that [ __ ] a [ __ ]
cheetah dude [ __ ] [ __ ] now so like
our design process so i'm like a shorts
connoisseur like i have if you go to my
house i have a [ __ ] ton so i took like
all my favorite pairs of shorts and we
pretty much cut them all up circled all
the things that we liked and we
frankenstein something out of like 10
different brands that we liked and then
from that you get the first uh prototype
right so you send the the what they call
like a tech pack in and then they send
you a prototype and then from there we
start making other like adjustments
because you know depending on the fabric
it could be the same pattern but if it's
fleece or corduroy or whatever it'll sit
differently so we would uh
do another revision another revision
another revision and then even with
when they dye it even the dye can change
the how a fabric sits i don't know if
you guys ever noticed but like let's say
you have a black t-shirt of course i
noticed a white shirt really
i don't know
i didn't notice so i'm really interested
to hear it brand a black t-shirt will
fit fit differently than a white t-shirt
the even the die like it it changes how
things fit so we had to custom uh choose
dies go back and forth a bunch and then
so finally once we get like a sample
that we're 100 on then they're able to
just make them wow did you also put into
the design to help your bulge because i
feel like it makes my bulge look very
favorable
support and
like i said man it like rubs against my
dick and makes me really i didn't do
that but we have an internal apparel i
didn't do that personally
but our internal apparel designer is a
pervert okay so she might have put that
in there
to be fair like women like wear push-up
bras and things that amplify you know
the cleavage and like the sexuality of
things not enough in my opinion
all i'm saying is like i
men should do it too i'm a fan of when
that happens therefore if you know we
want to be respectful and like do the
same for you know our women counterparts
i really think that you know the right
clothes should help you
look [ __ ] emphasized dude just put a
mag light in there what are you talking
about you know what that's so 90s if you
roll the quarters baby i wish it was the
material is a little thicker because
sometimes when i go pee i forget to like
shake and then i put the shorts back on
and then all that that's cause you're
not wearing underwear dog
like double duty shake that [ __ ] wear
some underwear you'd be fine and we
wanted it to be thinner so people could
swim in them and stuff i like yeah dude
that's one of my favorite things is
because you can swim enough
oh my god i have to get some now you
know it dries fast i take that's all i
take to hawaii i just bring two two
shorts that should last me a month yeah
look at the pockets
i'm sorry oh it doesn't
matter mesh so that the shorts uh the
pockets dry faster too no because i wear
one and then i swim and when i get out i
put on the dry ones and then the wet
ones they're already done by the end of
the day they're dry i could just never
rotate themselves
this is good advice from the most
disgusting person
you know no but then after i go in the
ocean i have to do the outdoor shower
because that takes all the
pee out yeah it's so true because you're
paying in the ocean most of the time and
on those
if you're peeing in the ocean do you
hike up one side and like
through the lake or you just pee
directly into the shore it depends if
there's kids or not
what's the difference if their kids are
for sure urine's out
under the kids in the ocean because if
there's people around they're going to
dive and see my dick right so i can't be
there like [ __ ] scoring like this and
just like that i can't do that face the
horizon no we can see your dick boom if
there's people i go inside and then as i
swim i do one of these things
and then i air it out i mean i water it
out right water it out yeah if i pee in
the ocean i do it while i'm like in
motion while i'm swimming it farther out
that's so hard let it go pee and swim at
the same time
yeah you're just kind of trying i'm not
swimming like an olympic swimmer i'm
just getting motion
versus versus being that one dude is
just kind of standing there by
themselves that's dude that's me no
that's my stance is my stance is like oh
that guy is definitely just peeing yeah
i always see that and i'm like what am i
not gonna do dude i'm always pretending
to look off but i'm really like i go
like that yeah yeah yeah oh oh what's
out there oh yeah and then when i'm done
peeing in the water i still shake a
little bit
that guy's finishing i'm taking my phone
out there to pretend like i'm like
vlogging or some [ __ ] and you're like
talking to yourself you're like hey yeah
really you're just peeing oh that's a
good move you guys are deceptive because
then people start looking up when really
down is what's happening oh that's smart
when you're doing something like that
how do you guys because you have a big
team how do you guys just go i don't
know you're going to say team but yes
i i would only talk about him having a
big team the only thing about him that's
big is his team
thank you
awesome today's video is brought to you
by feels all right cbd is not about what
you feel it's about what you do not feel
such as anxiety
stress
pain ah [ __ ] [ __ ] that hurts
and sometimes insomnia you're like oh
man i have to wake up at 5am what the
hell i gambled all night
and i need to sleep
yeah like yesterday we had an intense
work meeting right we were collaborating
throwing ideas at each other and you go
home you're so excited like oh i love
the just kidding news where it's going
to go next year oh yeah and then you
can't sleep so stimulating but we're
like we got to film today
so how do we chill out feels
right underneath the tongue
and it's that simple to do you just put
a few drops and then you have your
unwinding nighttime routine you know you
just relax
me i like to play the skin flute of
myself oh
plays the best tunes yeah i just go
and then i go to sleep
and that's like my pretty cool routine i
feel pretty good but maybe for you you
might be too intimidated and you're like
i don't know i don't know anything about
a cbd i don't know what to do well good
for you because feels has a hotline you
could call it and be like check this out
i'm a little scared i don't know how
much to use here what do you recommend
and they will help you out through the
whole process so you can have a great
sleep experience or whatever you trying
to do and accomplish with your cbd
experience
so yeah if you want to feel a little bit
of chill
take some cbd some feels play the skin
flute or the pink turntable that's up to
you but go to feels.com off the record
to get a sickle deal
50
off your first order and free shipping
that's 50 off your first order with free
shipping go to fields that's f e a l s
dot com slash off the record to get 50
off and free shipping uh no but how do
you guys go like okay this is done
what's finally finished or like how do
you refine that we actually don't know
so this is our what we call our mark
twos
um our first one
uh we thought that was perfected
and because we tested all different ways
all kinds of different training methods
like lifting swimming running whatever
and then one big problem that we had was
uh when you put something heavy in the
pocket like we tested like keys and
stuff yeah like it'll come out the
bottom like a lot of shorts yeah i have
that yeah and uh we're like oh [ __ ] so
we shortened and tapered the pocket by
like two inches and then one of the
other problems that we had was uh the
drawstring and laundry would pull out
yeah oh yeah i hate that so we fixed
those and then now after another year of
having the mark twos we're like okay
that's right the first version of the
shorts you gave me i told you that that
it happened and i lost the stream boom
new york mag right there
boom amphibious shorts mark ii new york
mag uh in top 10 shorts who's wearing it
i give 10 000 lululemon all these
[ __ ] shorts right road roan or
whatever
fabletics and we got [ __ ] barbell
brigade dude these are very good shorts
i don't feel like i'm a good friend
because i'm not wearing bart shorts
right now i'm wearing my visitors you're
wearing my friends that's cool too but
those shorts are actually really good
they're so good i like those shorts that
i think barbell should steal this
for version three i almost got that same
pair shout out to matt vincent he makes
great shorts too his shorts are really
good i just want it to match today right
here just so everyone else can see there
it is
that's the best shorts really dude i ate
that [ __ ] the other day it was good
you know what [ __ ] sucks dude so like
i think like my brain is kind of like
you're talking about uh mr was it doctor
dr hyde jekyll yeah yeah yeah dr jekyll
who [ __ ] that yeah yeah
or you have multiple personalities right
so there's a side of me that like is
super into like training and there's a
side of me that likes to be in like what
i call [ __ ] [ __ ] town and i was like i
was like how touch that patrol like
because we're coming out with new
patterns right i'm like how dope would
it be if i made the kovid 19 shorts
so all of them it's just a repeated
pattern of like the little virus all
over the place but then i'm like
[ __ ] is it not good when the two worlds
collide because then people like are you
trying to profit off of them like no i'm
just trying to make funny shorts i think
i've seen coveted t-shirts where it's
the [ __ ] like the virus yeah like
virus or like whatever yeah or when
people give you [ __ ] about the virus
just be like it's not the covid virus
it's a different virus yeah this is
delta these are the delta different dude
the variant shorts
so no matter how much they change it's
still a variant yeah three dude why not
but if i get in trouble huh if i came
out with now if you call it the variant
i think it's cool because that's like
it's like a half step towards it but
it's like you're so clear it's
amphibious dude you don't call it the
covet short but the low but the pattern
is going to be a little viruses all the
way across i think that's already
there's already clothes like oh really
yeah under a microscope dude it's all
the same oh god i've seen it at hot
topic yeah okay yeah those are hot topic
shorts
i don't know you want to be the first
one on the market with that no i'm
scared
right now it's 64. how much how much
would you say uh in terms of like
barbell brigade's brand because like
obviously from an outsider when i look
at barbra gate i obviously think about
the gym i obviously think about uh
apparel and clothing and i also think
about things like your protein and your
pre-workout and stuff like that is there
another sector that i'm not thinking
about outside of like content creation
and stuff like that no that's it okay so
out of those what would you actually say
is like the the true kind of bread and
butter that like lets that brand kind of
survive if you will the true bread and
butter
i would say it's actually probably the
content first
i'll be continuing yeah because that's
like both the marketing and also the
thing that like continues to bring in
and i think that's what people uh
connect with the brand where i think uh
the brand we feel like
it's we like we all like to train
hardcore but then we're pretty down to
earth and we all [ __ ] around so all of
our content is a little bit different
than like the rest of the fitness let me
rephrase just for fun what makes y'all
the most money
how it makes the most money apparel
clothes but if we did it right it should
be supplements
why is it [ __ ] [ __ ] town in your head
what's up with that
[ __ ] [ __ ] town yeah that's why i like to
party
well why isn't it [ __ ] city which is a
porno oh
a dame to come for
oh my god wait that's a parody that's
true
yeah sin city
is pretty good dude maybe [ __ ] [ __ ] city
in your head maybe not it's [ __ ]
[ __ ] man
yeah
like i
i know i'm in the right area
when i do something and i'm kind of
scared of what's going to happen after i
post something i see or if it comes out
of my mouth i'm kind of scared of the
repercussions but i like that danger
you should just create a
store called [ __ ] [ __ ] town that's
separate and you get to do whatever you
want like
i don't know like a store but it's like
you got coveted shorts you've got you
also have vaccine shorts as well to have
both probably gonna also need some [ __ ]
[ __ ] money to like do that with because
that's true kind of a [ __ ] idea
you could have the
covet apparel like you could have a
t-shirt that's like pfizer moderna
[ __ ] johnson and johnson it's called
johnson's johnson
like people could wear the vaccine that
they got and [ __ ] and then they got the
coverage i've seen that like i got
pfizer yeah yeah
yeah it's like nike but like yeah you're
sponsored sponsored by johnson and
johnson
i think you should take that that's a
good idea he just gave you gold right
now and you're sitting sitting down not
even writing this down i'm thinking
about you like fiat dollar currency that
might be a lot of like licensing
conflict but if you change what is it
like ten percent or something that was a
parody law that yeah you can do in [ __ ]
[ __ ] wizard doesn't have merch
dude they got murdered
oh i got the five
zebra i'd rock a fight
they should have visors
oh my god dude i can't wait till the day
that they have hooligans
of like modern hooligans and [ __ ]
johnson johnson and then they go on
fighting [ __ ] straight up
what vaccine did you get i got pfizer
you got visor okay cool so we're on the
same team we don't all right but we
should get visors visor visors we should
have the non-boxers and then also too
it's a visor with your pfizer vaccine
like on top and then the card
yes i could eat at this restaurant you
[ __ ] because when we were when we were
in hawaii it was kind of like because
they were asking everyone to show their
backs card yeah and like i get it
whatever you guys gotta do what you
gotta do but it is kind of a pain in the
ass to be like oh [ __ ] and to have
everything out but this way like you
have
you you rep your hood which is your
vaccine and you go like that and then
you flip it around and then you have
your card right there laminated i love
it where's your card dude my wife has it
johnson and joshua should do like stuff
like shorts too where it's like your car
is like by your dick so it's like
johnson johnson oh
yeah yeah that's a job just good
marketing or like it's like it's just
it's just one time because you only need
it one time oh yeah like yeah oh yeah
one time but then it's like a maybe a
maybe on the back like maybe it works
yeah maybe one time one hit or quitter
you get a yeah you get a booster t-shirt
they're loving their they're loving
their physics dude this is whack bro
the fact that they don't have a visor i
think is so stupid they need to come up
with a visor low-key a pfizer dad hat
will be pretty cool
like the shirt is kind of whack but the
the the dad hat yeah i mean
i mean i can't believe they have fizer
merch or a pfizer fanny maybe it's for
like um employee park day or something
you know or like one of those like
little pfizer balls you could put on a
car antenna oh yeah
that'd be cool they don't do those
anymore huh the jack of the box is the
best one hands down all the time do cars
even have car antennas anymore like that
no they're all short now yeah they're
all like slowly choking hey i don't have
an antenna or it's like all like in your
window or something yeah dude nobody
listens to the [ __ ] of the radio yeah
getting the pfizer gang man yes yeah
that's too cheesy bro dude they got
coveted merch man do they have non-vax
or merch okay this is what they need i
guarantee you they got non-bags
you guys gotta do a barbell do a barbell
brigade collab with your favorite
vaccine provider
oh you gotta get all the i think you got
to get all the vaccines dude that's my
[ __ ] idea right sir and johnson and
johnson you don't have enough of them
and then you need to have the covent
shorts and astrazeneca yeah i wonder if
like this is like her big break as a
modeling career oh my
all
gosh
you know what that looks like it looks
like a stock photo that they just
[ __ ] photoshopped text on yeah but
you know they they worked extra hard to
make the text like assimilate to the
fold of her shirt so
i think they maybe just actually printed
it because it's a you know those uh
stock photos for like
like random clothing like target
underwear or whatever yeah next to the
barbell office there's a photo studio
and i think that's where they shoot all
that stuff no way they just have random
models coming in
and then whatever they're shooting it's
oh it's like the same pose like oh buy
this inner tube for the pool like it's
always like that just generic that must
be a sweet gig dude
[ __ ] fast like the models that know
how to hit their looks yeah they're
[ __ ] they gotta practice that
i did find the opposite side shirt what
is it
this girl runs on jesus
that's tight that girl didn't get back
yeah no no no she don't believe in facts
i saw a model wearing that shirt exactly
next door that's a powerful shirt
concept like whoever really thought
about that bud light live that's the
best of both worlds i think bud light
lime is strong that's a strong position
[Music]
[Music]
you